[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu venho de uma casa onde as pessoas não
conversavam muito onde se vende o almoço
para comprar o jantar é uma casa de uma
mãe que criou três filhos sozinhas é
sozinho
e aí quando a vida melhorou resolvi que
estava a fazer a análise e aí eu fui
fazer a análise fiz por quase 20 anos e
num dia numa sessão de análise não leva
isso em conta uma história que falava de
um grupo de mães na era pré internet de
um grupo de mães em são francisco que
fazia uma coisa que era um mural onde
elas colocavam hoje eu preciso de ajuda
eu preciso que você venha buscar o meu
filho faça um lanche e deixa ele na
porta de casa sem tocar a campainha sem
falar comigo
a primeira vez que ela me contou isso eu
falei mas sem um papinho sem nada sem
uma conversa não vou perguntar pra essa
pessoa como ela está e ela me disse não
sem nada bom corta eu mudei para o
centro em março e em centro de são paulo
e vive a vida inteira em pinheiros e
mudei para o centro de são paulo
quando mudei para o centro eu entendi
muita coisa e me conhece o sal ea
gabriela eles são meus vizinhos
a gabriela tem 34 anos ela tem dois
filhos miguel maria luísa é o saulo nos
a verde porque ele é corintiano
a gabriela adora capinando gols e não
gosta de comida árabe
o sol ea gabriela é são casados usam
aliança adoram música eles têm deites às
sextas-feiras e o sol ea gabriela eles
são moradores de rua eles são mendigos a
gente chama como a gente quiser e o sol
ea gabriela me fizeram lembrar dessa
história de são francisco porque a
gabriela me encontra de manhã e me diz
ana cristina me dá dois reais para
cachaça
se começar o dia
ou o salame fala a dona cristina posso
testar o bluetooth do celular dessa
caixa de som ou a caixa a ele carrega
muita coisa é ele é carreteiro ea calça
dele quebrou a semana passada eu estava
precisando soldar o eixo e eu tenho
combinados com saulo que é que são eu a
gente tem uma relação muito nessa ela me
pede cachay eles me pedem cachaça ou
eles me pedem o que eles precisam e com
eles eu relembrei dessa história de são
francisco eu relembrei porque a gente
não consegue fazer o que o outro de fato
precisa que a gente faça porque a gente
precisa sempre concordar com que o outro
precisa e aí porque a gente não consegue
eu te peço x você faz x eu te entrego x
simples não tem de r não tem conversa
não tem nada e eu não tenho essa
resposta pra dar é tenho uma inquietação
de olhar as pessoas de escutar as
pessoas uma vontade de estar perto dessa
gente que a gente passa na rua sem saber
se está viva está morta
quando elas estão enroladas naquela
descoberta cinzas
a gente passa por elas ea gente não sabe
se elas estão vivas ou se elas estão
mortas
elas estão na calçada ea gente está com
medo que elas levem a nossa bolsa não
tem mais nada nada
ela só tem a vontade de dizer obrigado
eu não quero essa comida árabe que eu
não gosto de árabe e é um direito que as
pessoas têm a dignidade a humanidade e
que eu acho que a gente foi perdendo e
foi roubando aí no meio do caminho
umas das outras nesse dia tão importante
que são os 70 anos do declaração dos
direitos universais
então a minha pergunta final é a gente
está olhando para o lado
é isso a gente se encontra no carnaval
olhando para o lado obrigada
[Aplausos]